what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by today we have
some big news about Spider-Man 4
specifically coming from Tom Holland
Peter Parker himself and I gotta say we
have to give props to Tom Holland he's
come a long way from spoiler man where
he would kind of spoil things about
upcoming movies Avengers Infinity War
Avengers endgame upcoming Spider-Man
movies he has certainly come a very long
way and obviously he has been coached
but obviously he has grown and matured
and is pretty solid when it comes to
interviews now when it comes to giving
out information about upcoming
Spider-Man or Marvel movies that he is a
part of now I say this because Tom
Holland does have a great update for us
today about Spider-Man 4 but at the same
time he does not give away too much
information and in a couple of different
interviews he even says I can't say
anything about this so he's come a long
way but he also has kind of changed his
mind about a statement that he made in
the past something that he said in the
past was along the lines of I shouldn't
be playing Spider-Man for the rest of my
life and of course he didn't mean this
as I don't like the character I'm gonna
get bored with the character I am bored
with the character he simply meant it as
he should pass down that mantle to
somebody else at some point in time he
should move along with his acting career
and the character of his specific Peter
Parker and the MCU should also evolve
and also move on however in one of the
recent interviews that we're going to
talk about this is what he had to say I
feel like my agents and I have navigated
the industry in a really good way over
the last 10 years but that said if I
just play Spider-Man for the rest of my
life I'd still be the luckiest kid alive
so there's no complaints from me here so
Tom Holland right now is super happy
still playing Spider-Man Peter Parker
which is great because based off of what
we've heard so far he has signed a new
deal to play Spider-Man or I should say
to continue to play Spider-Man in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe possibly in
the Sony verse as well but he'll have a
lot to do with the MCU alone three more
Spider-Man films Spider-Man four five
and six two more Avengers films Kang
Dynasty and Secret Wars and one more
project that we're really unsure about
so far but another team up project so
let's talk about what he said in these
recent interviews giving us a little bit
of an update about Spider-Man 4
specifically talking about the script
also reminder if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe and if you
subscribe and leave a comment you're
entered in our giveaway for a chance to
win an Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel
Legends items or some DC items we pick
one winner at the end of each month and
the winner gets to pick one item so this
first interview that we're going to talk
about is an interview with inverse and
this was for the crowded room a project
that Tom Holland recently starred in and
actually produced himself now this
project took a lot out of him he said
both physically and mentally and due to
how hard this project was Tom Holland
said that he was taking a break from
acting for a year just a year he's not
done with acting altogether he is
returning a Spider-Man and in fact he is
talking about returning as Spider-Man
man in this interview so don't worry
about that and if you didn't know
Spider-Man 4 it probably isn't coming
till 2025 anyway so he has time to take
off but at the same time they are not
simply ignoring Spider-Man 4 because it
sounds like he is physically taking time
off of acting meaning he's not going to
be actually acting or doing any stunts
or performances or anything like that
but he is still meeting about the script
about the story about where Spider-Man 4
is going to go and he basically confirms
that by stating that he's already met
with the studios about the next
Spider-Man films now in this inverse
interview when he was asked about the
story of Spider-Man 4 and the project in
general he stated whether or not it'll
come to fruition who knows but right now
it's looking pretty good and we'll just
have to wait and see now I kind of want
to just say ignore that first part
Spider-Man 4 is happening and what's
really interesting is that Sony and
Marvel Studios already both told us they
actually told us like a week after
Spider-Man no way home released Sony
executive to producer Amy Pascal and
Marvel Studios president Kevin feige
came out and stated they have already
begun working on Spider-Man 4 the next
movie plus not to mention in the
interviews for Spider-Man across the
spider-verse again Sony executive
producer Amy Pascal came out and said
yes they are working on the next
Spider-Man film right now and in another
interview for the crowded room Tom
Holland actually had a different answer
it was before this interview and he
stated that they have met about the
movie it is in development but they
stopped because of the wga strike so
this first part where he says whether or
not it'll come to fruition who knows I
think that's simply to keep people on
their toes and not really give too much
away like I said Tom Holland's come a
pretty long way from spoiler man in fact
in a separate interview with Yahoo They
asked him about the next Spider-Man
movie and he says I'm going to have to
plead the fifth here because I'm not
prepared to start talking about the
future of Spider-Man really kind of just
shutting it down right away he doesn't
want to say too much he doesn't want to
give anything away not say anything he's
not supposed to however he does go on to
say in this interview with Yahoo as
everyone knows I love him he changed my
life I love the character should we find
a way to tell his story and do justice
to him we will do so but if we can't
find a way to do that and if we can't
find a way to compete with the third one
then you know he'll swing off into the
sunset now again I believe what he is
saying is true but don't let that fool
you they are making a Spider-Man 4. but
I believe what he is saying is true they
need to do Spider-Man Justice or it's
not really gonna work for him but
luckily for us we kind of know the
direction that they are going to take
Spider-Man in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe one we've heard that he's going
to be one of the leads for both Avengers
the King Dynasty and Avengers Secret
Wars now don't be confused with the
leader of these movies he is simply
going to be one of the lead actors not
the leader of the new Avengers team that
will most likely Fall to somebody like
Bruce Banner or Captain America Erica
Sam Wilson if Hawkeye jumps back into
the mix of it he's one of the ogs as
well or perhaps Doctor Strange is the
one that steps up but no doubt they're
gonna offer Tom Holland a lot of money
to return to Spider-Man and star in
these two new Avengers films that we
have coming up but as far as the
Spider-Man films are concerned they have
already teased Venom and I'm sure this
is something that Tom Holland is not
going to want to turn down a chance to
get the Venom symbiote or fight against
Venom himself and that was the teaser
after Spider-Man no way home that's what
they set up plus not to mention at the
same time they are setting up Kingpin to
be a major Spider-Man villain and not
just a Spider-Man villain but just a big
bad in general as a part of the MCU he
appeared in Hawkeye he is now going to
appear in the Echo series and of course
he's going to be the big bad of the
Daredevil series and hopefully this is
building up to a Spider-Man Daredevil
team up to go up against Kingpin
possibly a Sinister Six both of which
would be just crazy awesome to see on
screen and would be a fantastic story
that would do Spider-Man himself justice
so right now we have two different story
lines that are going to happen in the
MCU Venom and Kingpin at least that is
what Marvel studios's plan seems to be
of course those plans can always change
but having Tom Holland's Peter Parker
get the Venom symbiote is going to be
awesome hopefully he gets this in secret
Wars like he does in the comics and
hopefully we get a project or a solo
movie where he uses it for good and uses
the strength of it to defeat whoever he
is fighting and then eventually has to
kind of fight the Symbiote himself get
rid of it then it jumps to Eddie Brock
and then he fights Eddie Brock and Venom
heck maybe at some point in time he even
uses the Venom symbiote to fight against
Kingpin imagine Venom Symbiote
Spider-Man fighting alongside Daredevil
going up against Kingpin that would be
insane and something that I definitely
think Tom Holland would really enjoy and
something that would progress the
character plus we already know that
Zendaya is returning for Spider-Man 4 as
well this is confirmed and I'm sure Tom
Holland wants to work with Zendaya again
and I'm sure they want to finish that
story because the last time I we left
them in the MCU MJ had no idea who Peter
Parker was and if Zendaya is returning
for the film that most likely means that
that spell is going to be undone in some
way shape or form or perhaps they loved
each other so much that MJ starts to
Simply remember who Peter Parker is who
knows the point is there's a lot of
story left to tell and Tom Holland wants
to tell that story he just needs it to
be a good story but we already know the
movie's confirmed they're working on it
Tom Holland has renewed his contract
he's simply trying to play it safe by
Stadium hay maybe we'll make the movie
hey yeah maybe I'll come back I plead
the fifth I can't talk about it this is
just his way of stating hey I don't want
to get in trouble I don't want to talk
about the movie because hey I've gotten
in trouble in the past so have no fear
Spider-Man 4 is happening Spider-Man 4 5
and 6 are happening and apparently the
story for Spider-Man 4 right now is
really good Tom Holland is really
excited about it and we are too we can't
wait to see it it's supposed to come out
before the King Dynasty According to
some insiders but we'll have to wait and
see on that release date in the meantime
don't forget to subscribe so you can
stay up to date on all the latest
Spider-Man news don't forget to enter
our give away and follow us on Instagram
and Twitter as well we're also on
patreon we'll link our patreon our
website and our Discord server down
below if you want to help support the
channel and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf
foreign